[Música]
un vídeo verificado por la agencia
reuters muestra cómo los guardias de
seguridad de Ciudad Juárez en México no
abrieron las rejas a los migrantes a
pesar de que el incendio ya había
comenzado y en cambio se retiran por ese
momento al presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador afirmó que habrá
investigaciones
el Rey Carlos III comenzó su primer
viaje como monarca de Reino Unido y lo
hizo en Alemania a donde aterrizó este
miércoles el primero en recibirlo fue el
presidente alemán Frank Walter stem
Mayer tenemos los detalles de la visita
desde Berlín
choque de declaraciones entre Israel y
Estados Unidos El Primer Ministro
Benjamín defendió que era decisión de su
pueblo hacer la reforma judicial que
promueve su gobierno una modificación
que vaiden invitó a pausar y queda
despertado protestas ampliamos con
nuestro corazón
buenas tardes y bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 yo soy María Clara
calle y les doy la bienvenida
empezamos en México un video publicado
por la agencia roviters muestra como los
guardias del centro de detención de
migrantes en Ciudad Juárez no abrieron
las rejas cuando el incendio comenzó en
el vídeo se ve como las personas
atrapadas patean Las rejas para escapar
mientras dos guardias salen del recinto
en esos momentos el Instituto Nacional
de Migración afirma que 38 personas
fallecieron y grupos de activistas
denuncian la responsabilidad de los
funcionarios en las muertes por la
supuesta inacción Andrés granadillo nos
amplía
en las imágenes de las cámaras de
seguridad de la estación del Instituto
Nacional de Migración en Ciudad Juárez
se ve el momento en el que inicia el
incendio en el que murieron 38 migrantes
y a unos guardias de seguridad que pasan
frente a la cámara y parecen salir del
recinto al menos hasta ese momento no
abren las puertas de las celdas donde
estaban los detenidos el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador quien había
responsabilizado del incidente a los
migrantes en el centro por según él
oponerse a ser deportados y un giro a
sus declaraciones y dijo que
investigaría los hechos debido a las
nuevas versiones que han salido a la luz
se están haciendo
todas las investigaciones para
conocer lo que realmente
sucedió una información preliminar pero
queremos tener
todos los elementos para informar
si es posible hoy mismo
informar sobre lo que sucedió
en
la versión de
el gobierno que represento
al frente del centro donde ocurrió la
conflagración un grupo de migrantes
protestaba por la falta de información y
por el trato que han recibido
a toda esa persona que tuvieron ahí que
fallecieron les pudieron abrir la reja
porque de la reja a donde se para los
agentes de migración son
ni metros hay un tremendo hermetismo hay
mucho silencio nadie dice nada el
Gobierno Federal ni migración ni el
gobierno del Estado ni el gobierno
municipal en medio de la oleada
migratoria que enfrenta a México el
embajador de Estados Unidos en este país
que en Salazar dijo que la tragedia era
un recordatorio para los gobiernos de la
región de la importancia de arreglar un
sistema migratorio que no funciona y los
riesgos de la migración irregular el
gobierno colombiano llamó a consulta a
su delegación que negocia un proceso de
paz con la guerrilla del eln el
presidente Gustavo Petro dio la noticia
a través de su cuenta de Twitter después
de que presuntamente ese grupo armado
emboscará un puesto del ejército en el
municipio del Carmen en la región
fronteriza del catatumbo en el noreste
de Colombia en el ataque murieron nueve
militares y ocho resultaron heridos el
gobierno local afirma que los soldados
estaban durmiendo cuando les dispararon
en las dos rondas de diálogos que han
tenido con el eln no han logrado pactar
un cese al fuego así se pronunció el
Ministerio de defensa colombiano
el presidente
acaba de llamar a la delegación de la
mesa de negociación con el ejército de
liberación nacional
ha llamado a conversaciones para
examinar este que es un hecho realmente
muy grave
que lamentamos
Estados Unidos respaldó la idea que
propuso el presidente colombiano Gustavo
Petro para realizar una conferencia
internacional sobre Venezuela e intentar
así resolver la crisis política del país
el encargado del departamento de estado
para América Latina Brian Nichols afirmó
que Washington está dispuesto a
participar en un eventual diálogo y que
la administración de Joe biden está
abierta a levantar las sanciones contra
Caracas si avanzan las negociaciones
entre el gobierno de Nicolás maduro y la
oposición actualmente ambas partes
dialogan en México y la propuesta de
Petro sería una mesa diferente
pasábamos a noticias de Europa el rey de
Reino Unido Carlos tercero llegó a
Berlín Esta es su primera visita al
extranjero como monarca y se da antes de
su coronación el 6 de mayo el plan
original sin embargo era que el rey
visitara primero Francia pero canceló su
viaje por las protestas contra la
reforma pensional nuestro corresponsal
en Alemania Thomas Sparrow tiene los
detalles de la visita
es absolutamente Claro que la visita del
Rey Carlos a Alemania está cargada de
simbolismo Y eso quedó en evidencia
Desde los primeros minutos después de su
llegada a Berlín donde fue recibido con
honores militares en uno de los
principales símbolos de la capital de
Alemania la puerta de brandeburgo fue
una recepción Por cierto extremadamente
inusual para Alemania pues las
recepciones de este tipo se realizan
normalmente en el Palacio presidencial
Pero también es claro que el Rey Carlos
quiere que su visita a Alemania vaya
mucho más allá de ese simbolismo vaya
mucho más allá de enfatizar las
relaciones entre Reino Unido y Alemania
también quiere que esa visita tenga un
claro componente político enfocado en
particular en temas como la lucha contra
el cambio climático la sostenibilidad y
la energía verde son tres temas que
están presentes en la agenda de la
visita del Rey Carlos una visita de tres
días en la que no solamente estará
visitando Berlín y sus alrededores sino
en la que también viajará en tren a
Hamburgo en el norte del país el Primer
Ministro de Israel Benjamín reaccionó en
contra de las declaraciones de su
homólogo estadounidense Joe biden quien
ayer invitó a netanyahu a que detenga su
polémica propuesta para reformar el
sistema de Justicia esto en medio de las
multitudinarias protestas que no cesan a
pesar de la suspensión del trámite
legislativo de la reforma sobre la
respuesta de netanyahu nos amplía desde
Jerusalén el corresponsal de France 24
para Israel y los territorios palestinos
Federico cueva Barberena
a la crisis interna por la reforma
judicial Israel ahora suma Una
inesperada grieta internacional con su
máximo Aliado Estados Unidos en una
declaración inusual el presidente Joe
biden se mostró muy preocupado por los
proyectos de ley de la coalición de
Benjamín neta ñahu al que instó
abandonar la reforma porque si no Israel
se dirigirá en sus palabras hacia un
camino muy peligroso también contrario a
lo reportado por el diario de New York
Times en biden negó que vaya a invitar a
netaniazco a la casa blanca al menos en
un corto plazo Aunque Washington ya
había dejado entrever su malestar con la
reforma de estas críticas tan directas
de biden han generado sorpresa en el
gobierno israelí rápidamente netanyahu
respondió que más allá de la gran
relación con Estados Unidos y con biden
Israel toma sus decisiones por la
voluntad de su pueblo y no por presiones
externas incluso de sus mejores amigos
luego en un foro sobre democracia
organizado por el Departamento de estado
el Primer Ministro calificó la alianza
con Estados Unidos de inquebrantable y
se mostró confiado en conseguir una
reforma por consenso menos cálida se
fueron las reacciones de los comentarios
del partido de netanyahu del dicut que
consideraron lo dicho por biden una
injerencia o del ministro de seguridad
nacional itamar venga y vivir quien
remarcó que Israel es soberano y no una
estrella más de la bandera
estadounidense con Washington opositores
y manifestantes mirando de reojo el
llamado al diálogo de netaniagu el
presidente Isaac gersoc continúa su
Ronda de reuniones con los partidos
políticos en busca de una propuesta
consensuada de reforma una iniciativa
que no ha logrado Apagar del todo las
protestas que aunque mucho menos
numerosas se dan seguido registrando
ante la VIP y otras ciudades el Papa
Francisco está internado en el hospital
yemely en Roma luego de ir para un
control de rutina el portavoz del
Vaticano Mateo bruni Solo precisó que
los chequeos estaban programados y que
antes el pontífice había presidido la
tradicional audiencia general de los
miércoles pero no dio más detalles el
medio italiano corría de la acera
sostiene que Fuentes vaticanas aclararon
que se canceló toda la agenda que el
jerarca católico tenía para el jueves y
el viernes
sitio web agrega que estaría internado
por un problema cardíaco Aunque el papá
sufrió en 2021 de divertículos que son
unos pequeños bultos acumulados en
alcohol
el presidente argentino Alberto
Fernández está de viaje oficial en
Estados Unidos ayer se reunió de Nueva
York con el secretario general de
Naciones Unidas Antonio Gutiérrez a
quien le pidió reanudar las
negociaciones por la soberanía de las
Islas malvinas que estaban bajo control
británico y este miércoles Fernández
será recibido por su homólogo
estadounidense Joe biden con la deuda
con el fondo monetario internacional
como uno de los temas centrales mientras
el ministro de economía argentino se
reúne con la directora gerente del fondo
Ramiro cueva berena tiene los detalles
el presidente Argentina Alberto
Fernández continúa su gira por Estados
Unidos luego derribar el domingo el
recorrido siguió en la sede Naciones
Unidas donde tuvo un encuentro con el
secretario general Antonio Gutiérrez
sobre la mesa estuvieron los problemas
globales pero también un asunto
trascendental para la política Argentina
la soberanía de las Islas malvinas
me reuní con el secretario general de la
ONU Antonio Gutiérrez analizamos los
desafíos de la coyuntura internacional y
les reiteré la solicitud de la Argentina
de reanudar las negociaciones para
encontrar una pronta y pacífica solución
a la disputa de soberanía sobre malvinas
este miércoles Fernández se verá con el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
en el marco de la celebración por los
200 años de relaciones bilaterales la
Casa Blanca ha catalogado a Argentina
como un Aliado clave en la región si
bien no hay agenda confirmada la
inmigración en América el cambio
climático y la guerra en Ucrania se
prueben como los asuntos principales
Fernández Espera que esto profundice Los
lazos con Washington
que progresemos en nuestro vínculo con
los Estados Unidos
no tenemos una agenda definida la cual
es una posibilidad de hablar de todo el
ministro de economía argentino Sergio
massa también estará en la reunión con
biden desde Buenos Aires buscan el
respaldo estadounidense de Cara a la
cuarta revisión del programa de
facilidades extendidas del fondo
monetario internacional
una aprobación le permitiría a Argentina
recibir 5.300 millones de dólares un
monto necesario en un contexto económico
delicado
de Taiwán
ya despegó hacia América en un intento
por afianzar las relaciones diplomáticas
a medida que disminuye el número de
países que reconocen Oficialmente de la
soberanía de La Isla frente a China
primero hará escala en Estados Unidos y
luego viajar a Guatemala y Belice un
viaje que Beijing rechaza como ya ha
hecho varias veces la presidenta
taiwanesa se sube a un avión con destino
a Estados Unidos pasando por
Centroamérica esta vez Es diferente las
crecientes tensiones con Washington hace
que Beijing no permita que este viaje
pase desapercibido
instamos a Estados Unidos a Que respete
estrictamente el principio de una sola
China y los tres comunicados conjuntos
china Estados Unidos que no permita
transitar por Estados Unidos ni siquiera
contactar con funcionarios
estadounidenses el presidente de la
cámara de representantes Kevin mccarthy
tiene otra idea y quiere reunirse con la
presidenta sai cuando aterriza en
California un alto funcionario
estadounidense defendió su viaje de los
periodistas que la respuesta de Beijing
era una reacción exagerada el año pasado
la visita a Taiwán en la predecesora de
mccarthy Nancy pelosi enfureció a China
que envió a sus fuerzas armadas a
realizar ejercicios a gran escala
alrededor de La Isla sus paradas en
Nueva York que los Ángeles completarán
la gira de 10 días de sai cuyo principal
objetivo es ir a Guatemala y Belice para
reforzar las relaciones son dos de los
13 países que siguen reconociendo a
taipei después de que Honduras el fin de
semana cambiara su lealtad y reconociera
a China antes de tomar el avión la
presidenta taiwanesa prometió resistir
las presiones de Beijing
la presión externa no obstaculizará
nuestra determinación de globalizarnos
estamos tranquilos y confiados no
sucumbiremos y no provocaremos a otros
Beijing reclama La Isla democrática y
autogobernada y dice que un día hará
parte de China continental
Indonesia ya no será la sede del mundial
de fútbol sub-20 la decisión la tomó la
FIFA luego de que la federación de aquel
país rechazara la presencia de Israel en
el Torneo el organismo de fútbol
indonesio tenía previsto el sorteo para
el viernes pero lo canceló en protesta
contra los israelíes la FIFA reaccionó
diciendo que el país no cumplió con Los
acuerdos pactados en su candidatura aún
no se conoce Cuál será la nueva sede
pero argentina se ofreció como
alternativa Indonesia es el país con más
musulmanes en el mundo y ha sido
escenario de protestas en contra del
equipo de Israel uno de los clasificados
así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que consulten más en
nuestra página web
trans24.com nosotros volvemos en minutos
[Música]